I moved to the United States four years
ago to live with my family
I have a background in social media by
doing the same was difficult here
more so because my English is not that
good
I chose the professional certification
program to enhance my skills
it has helped me make significant
progress I am already using these kids
to sell my products online
hey I'm David Villegas I live in
Missouri United States with my family
until four years ago I was living and
working in Bolivia my home country I was
working with you and a woman as a
graphic designer I moved here to live
with my family
my academic background lies in social
communication and graphic design I have
always been inclined towards social
media and its marketing aspects and
various platforms but I lack the
required professional skills and
expertise
so to sustain I started doing some odds
jobs here which I'm still doing
apart from that I'm also attending
college at the North Central Technical
College
last year I decided to pursue the
professional certification program in
digital marketing from Purdue University
offered by simple learner I like that it
could provide such as flexible schedule
for attending the live classes it came
with a recorded feature with a blessing
for working professionals like me
apart from that I like that we have to
do projects and assignments after every
model
here there I have no idea what CEO or
web analytics were
but now I have learned these Concepts
and I'm using them on a daily basis my
goal is to run my own digital marketing
agency one day it's in the process and I
believe that the course will help me to
do it in a better way but I'm not
working or studying I'm busy taking
photographs it's one of my hobbies
I believe that I have come one step
closer to living my dream life in
America
I am glad that I made the right choice
to upskill myself
[Music]